bonsoir alafé wakili merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce soir sur
rtl france les bureaux de vote ont fermé
comment s'est passée cette journée il ya
eu de grands moments du moins deux
images de tendance dans une partie du
pays le vote s'est relativement bien
déroulée notamment à abidjan
et il ya des zones où le vote n'a pas pu
se dérouler et à dans d'autres zones
moussa s'est déroulé aussi sans
difficultés majeures notamment au nord
du pays quand on peut considérer nos
trois grandes zones à bis talent tout le
centre au centre ouest du pays
et puis le non plus considérer qu'un
bond à lens en a à peu près 75 80 % des
bureaux de voix qu'en way car 75 80 % du
territoire un pu voter
il ya aussi beaucoup de n'y vois rien
qui ont brûlé leur carte électorale
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire selon vous ce
soir de la participation
on a participation sera certainement
moyenne je ne sais pas si on pourra
atteindre le taux de 50% on n'en sait
rien pour l'instant
toujours est il que quand on pensait
cartographie pour dire qu'il ya des
zones où les gens ont beaucoup voté il
ya des zones où il ya eu un vote moyens
et puis des zones wi a pas eu du tout de
voir à environ 25% de la population
électorale du territoire électoral
on fera le point et faut noter que en
jeu
peut-être un moment c'était le taux de
participation mais l'enjeu n'était que
les élections ne se tiennent pas
l'élection s'est tenue
donc même si on avait eu un taux de
participation extraordinaire
l'opposition ne l'est toujours pas
reconnu l'élection donc
le taux de participation ne change pas
grand chose dans la posture ce qui
voulons qu'ils ne voulaient pas
l'élection dont il ya un débat qui
entrent et d'être surtout de
participation s'était pas sans mon jeu
l'enjeu était que l'élection n'ait pas
lieu
l'élection a eu lieu est ce qu'il faut
considérer détail les circonstances et
tout le reste il faut aussi au passage
déploré les victimes
il faut déplorer qui est encore démons
ne sais pas le nombre exact ajouté au no
homo qu'on a déjà eu il faut déplorer
tout cela est souhaité que des
dispositions soient prises pour qu'on
sorte de cette spirale le mot élèves et
il s'est déjà beaucoup on est encore
loin peut-être du taux de 3000 morts de
2010 2011 mais ça monte doucement
doucement et attention il faut
absolument éviter cela quelles que
soient les différences et magasins et
des autres soient les oppositions qui a
déjà parlé d'un échec en tout cas de de
ce qu'elle appelle un coup d'état
institutionnel ce soir ce sont des
paroles qui ne sont pas véritablement
apaisante en tout cas elles sont pas
présentes mais elles ne sont pas
étonnant non plus ces paroles puisque
l'opposition l'objectif le plus cher
était d'empêcher ce coup d'état
il a eu lieu d'après elle pense que
c'est l'échec bon un coup d'état et
russie où il ne réussit pas il a été
fait on dit c'est un échec mais il a
produit des effets je ne sais pas on
nous annonce un gouvernement parallèle
maintenant nous sommes à les salaires du
mois d'octobre était déjà plié les
décisions doivent être prises la côte
d'ivoire d'être représentés avec des
nationales des dispositions doivent être
doivent être prises pour la
représentation de la côte d'ivoire 6ème
réunion à l'international si la
démission a fait je ne sais pas ce
gouvernement qui va être fort mais quels
moyens il y aura ou travailler pour
représenter la côte d'ivoire comment il
va organiser une élection ouverte
transparente comment il va mettre en
place des institutions de nouvelles pour
laisser voir des candidats nouveau une
nouvelle
commission électorale et nouveau code
électoral peut-être un nouveau conseil
constitutionnel
on est parti pour une longue crise ça
peut durer un mois deux mois mais aussi
ça peut durer cinq ans c'est à dire que
l'objectif est d'obtenir un nouveau
cycle électoral qui permettent d'élire
un nouveau président de la république ça
peut durer un mois deux mois
l'opposition peut gagner son combat et
sa beauté de dieu et cinq ans parce que
à l'époque un 95-82 prise habité jusqu'à
en 2002 le processus institutionnel de
la vie démocratique est interrompue par
une attaque entreprises dans barreaux
elle finalement il est resté jusqu'en
2010 et depuis 2010 tous un peu de
personnes ont parié que le président
alassane ouattara est resté au gua
aujourd'hui il est là c'est possible que
tout ça est ce que tu es belle de mai
mais aussi c'est pas impossible que ça
continue jusqu'en 2025
donc tous les possibles encore
aujourd'hui à partir de demain on va
observer comment les choses vont se
passer
la commission électorale doit se réunir
les résultats selon vous pourrait être
annoncée quand il ya une nuit électorat
qui est prévue ce soir
les résultats seront donnés au fur et à
mesure qu'ils parviendront et je pense
jusqu'au matin les dispositions
sécuritaires ont été prises bout que
c'est tellement jusqu'à dimanche pour
les résultats soient donnés jusqu'à
demain midi ou de mesoa et
éventuellement le conseil
constitutionnel pourrait entrer en
action lundi ou mardi les choses
devraient aller vite parce que ya pas
beaucoup de contestations ya pas voilà
il n'y a pas eu d'adversaire et
l'opposition significative titan n'a pas
participé à l'élection donc il devrait
pas avoir beaucoup de contestations sur
les bulletins des procès verbaux et les
résultats devraient pourraient donner
rapidement on a parlé de certaines
violences néanmoins dans le pays des
maisons qui aurait été
il est des bureaux de vote bloqué du
matériel électoral également un brûlé
quant à la bonne tenue de ces élections
est ce que suffisamment d'observateurs
ont pu être présent oui les deux os et
21 ans étaient présents et plus on ne
peut que vous voyez au delà des
conditions qui permet d'arriver à
l'élection
le changement c'est le jour de
l'élection le jour de l'élection est un
jour qui est un jour de mobilisation
avec la présence lorsqu'il ya des
candidats c'est fictif et ce lieu avec
la présence d'éric de l'entente dans les
bureaux de vote nous avons le 20000 de
l'eau de vote
sinon positions significatives avaient
été présente en plus des observateurs
nationaux et internationaux il y en a eu
jusqu'à 10000 au total
je pense que l'on aurait été possible
d'obtenir moment de l'élection mais les
conditions de la transparence et à
empêcher tout tripatouillage
parce qu'on peut bien préparer
l'élection on peut avoir peur des
commissions sur papier mais l'ange
rennes c'est le jour tu vois que
mobiliser les électeurs et qu'on a fini
de mobilier les lecteurs assurer
l'intégrité de tous les acteurs du
processus et a dit les représentants des
candidats
les membres de la commission électorale
qui sont là sur le terrain tous ceux qui
participent au processus pour que chacun
à son niveau sur intel celeron aux
derniers stades au niveau de la
commission centrale ou dollars pour le
commission électorale que les choses se
passer sur le terrain dans les plans des
votes avec les pv doucement doucement ça
remonte tout une chaise toute une
filière
hélas ce qui s'est passé avec ce que
l'on a vu avec les processus de
dépouillement et c'est monté un
processus de transparence et
d'observation qui est là et qui sera
difficile de manipuler de maquiller
durablement et de façon outrageuse des
résultats et concernant leur est ce
qu'il ya eu comme mort destruction comme
violence comme des gars il faut le
déplorer et plus noté qu' il ya eu aussi
une attitude des forces de sécurité
east et est entendu que les manifestants
n'étaient pas peut-être armés d'armes de
guerre et de destruction massive avec
quelques fusils des matches elle devance
bien couper les arbres
il a été retenu de ne pas utiliser la
violence
ford la violence d'état entre ces
manifestants tant que une le départ
qu'il n'était pas question qu est
d'empêcher absolument de partie de vos
détaillants et par d'affrontements
imminent n'y avait pas de légitime
défense
un bar à sourire malgré que les fuites
il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de victimes
depuis aujourd'hui et puis l'ensemble
des manifestations appels des victimes
liées à l'action des riposte des forces
de sécurité de la voie c'est tellement
mais qui alla peut pour l'instant parce
que ça fait partie aussi des consignes
ont été données aux forces de sécurité
pour éviter de faire usage de leurs
moyens qui peuvent connu plus de
victimes que les moyens les conflits
entre l afe wattv quel est l'état
d'esprit des ivoiriens ce soir on parle
d'une certaine résignation quant à un
troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara non
si c'est mitigé voyez vous en réalité il
ya une partie effectivement qui comprend
que la constitution ne lui permettait
pas d'être candidat lui il a des
partisans il a des soutiens qui l'ont
soutenu lundi dont ils ont pris des ce
faire ils se sont résignés mais les
hôtesses sont pas encore résigné la
désalpe décès qui se sont pas encore
désignés qui annoncent qu'ils vont pas
laisser tomber le combat et c'était ma
partie des deux mais ils vont continuer
de le contester ils ne le reconnaissent
pas la question est de savoir combien de
temps la crise reprend puisque longtemps
des discussions sont un visage et comme
étant la crise aura pas parce que aussi
le mandat des députés prendra fin
bientôt il faudra songer à mettre en
place une nouvelle assemblée nationale
est ce que ces partis politiques auront
les moyens de mettet ni leur cohésion
c'est
lille 2 qui était candidat à l'élection
présidentielle maintenant et à 255 ou
275 peut-être bientôt autres députés qui
sont en jeu est-ce qu'il est évident que
compte tenu de tout ce temps du
rendement
alassane ouattara et le rhdp peut avoir
la majorité à l'assemblée nationale
faut-il continuer a dit non à son mandat
refusé d'aller aux législatives et c'est
une opportunité d'envoi une majorité par
le marais imposé d'avoir le contrôle du
gouvernement
voici des questions auxquelles
l'opposition devra répondre parce
qu'elle ne s'est pas encore résigné
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
ont dû arrêter les ivoiriens non les
partisans du présentateur sont d'accord
qu'il fasse son mandat le 1er la panam
de briscous le troisième mandat mais
l'opposition n'hésite pas encore
totalement l'exigé la question de savoir
dans les semaines à venir les mois mais
ni comment elles loi organiser la lutte
par rapport aux élections législatives
qui arrivait aussi comment au délà des
partis politiques qui vont m'aider de
gamme peut être en place les mets usure
et de l'opposition
il ya une cinquantaine commun mais
chacune des 100 lumens qui est président
du conseil régional va gérer sa relation
avec le pouvoir central
comment aussi sa qualité de président et
f pays va produire à conserver alors
qu'il a obtenu grâce à une justice qui
étaient sous les ordres du goût et mac
dont on est tenté de voir comment tout
ça va se passer dans les mains courtes
on verra cela merci beaucoup à la fée ou
et qu'il est d'avoir répondu ce soir à
nos questions sur arte france